avec sébastien boussois chercheur en
sciences politiques et relations euro
arabe associé à l'ulb bonjour et merci
d'être avec nous qu'est ce que ça vous
inspire cette confirmation par ben
bernanke à washington fait donc pression
sur ses partenaires européens concernant
l'accord sion nucléaire iranien dirais
que c'est un secret de polichinelle
d'une part parce qu'on est dans la
diplomatie du dollar concernant les
pressions américaines et puis que
finalement berlin s'est retrouvé dans
une situation avec les autres états
membres de pression parce que c'est
comme s'il n'y avait pas véritablement
le choix en réalité pour les états
membres de l'union européenne que de
suivre les états unis et on voit bien
même si washington a été le premier à
détricoter cet accord les états membres
ont très rapidement suivi il suffit de
voir avec la france total s'est empressé
de se retirer d'un des plus gros contrat
de l'histoire qu'il avait eu avec l'iran
d'autres entreprises ont fait de même et
finalement se rend compte que même si
l'union européenne essaie de peser
essaie de préserver cet accord comme
beaucoup l'ont souhaité un accord
reconnu par les nations unies que
téhéran suivaient jusque là partir du
moment où washington a commencé à
détricoter cette histoire on s'est
retrouvé avec des états membres qui
n'ont pas été capables de suivre et
l'attaquent de roanne et pour le coup
était tout à fait juste puisque les
états auraient dû faire ça un secret de
polichinelle dites vous que cette
pression de washington sur l'europe mais
pour quelle raison est ce qu'aujourd'hui
berlin mais slave sur le devant de la
table celle envie de prendre ses
distances avec les états unis
je crois qu'aujourd'hui effectivement
l'allemagne essaie de prendre incertaine
un certain écart mais que finalement que
ça soit berlin que ce soit paris face à
washington ils ne parviennent pas ils
n'arrivent pas à peser
il ya toujours de la part des états
membres est en tout cas ceux qui sont le
plus important ce qui essaye à chaque
fois de relancer la machine diplomatique
européenne
une volonté d'essayer de se démarquer à
un moment ou un autre et le rendre
l'airé des états unis responsables de
tous les européens savent très bien tout
seuls comme des grands aussi se tirer
une balle dans le pied et sur l'accord
sur le nucléaire
je dois bien reconnaître qu'ils n'ont
pas été forcément très brillant et qui
n'ont pas réussi de toute façon à peser
face à washington
cet après midi à londres le canada
l'ukraine la suède et l'afghanistan est
donc évidemment les anglais vont
réfléchir à d'éventuelles compensations
financières après la mort de soixante
276 personnes dans un avion abattu on le
rappelle par erreur par les autorités
par les forces armées iraniennes
qu'est ce qu'on peut attendre de cette
réunion comme vous le dites des
compensations malheureusement quoi
d'autre donald trump mais le feu il crée
à la fois le virus et de le côté n'a pas
l'antidote il a poussé les pression
maximale je dirais militaire et
politique parce qu'il était parfait ils
n'étaient pas parvenus à une pression
économique suffisante avec l'iran je
dirais qu'il a mis l'iran et téhéran un
peu sous tension il ya une
responsabilité claire et nette de
l'armée iranienne et roanne in ne le
cache pas malheureusement à part d'ea
par des compensations pour les familles
des victimes quoi faire d'autre
l'enquète prouve à ce stade là et la
presse il ya joué un rôle important
qu'on ait effectivement a2micile qui se
sont abattues sur l'avion est évidemment
l'issue a été a été tragique alors de là
à ce que les iraniens nous explique que
c'est parce qu'il était sous stress avec
les états unis évidemment on ne serait
pas pressés qu'ils l arme nucléaire
alors à san juan a appelé à l'unité
nationale après donc le retard pris par
les autorités pour un reconnaître leur
responsabilité dans ce crash aérien il
appelle un changement radical en
politique il est mise en difficulté
aujourd'hui le pouvoir iranien pouvoir
iranien est mis en difficulté en même
temps je crois que personne n'aspire à
une déstabilisation ou un renversement
ou à une transformation trop rapide
en réalité tout le monde critique le
régime comme l'on dit des mollahs et
puis finalement c'est qu'au février au
mois de février des élections
législatives rohani se séparent ou se
dédouane ne se dégage de l'armée pour
essayer de se préserver probablement
quand il parle d'un changement radical
ça peut forcément peut-être faire
sourire ce que veulent les iraniens qui
ont manifesté contre le régime
ce que veulent les iraniens qui
évidemment ne peuvent pas cautionner ce
qui s'est passé avec cet avion et la
mort de 176 victimes qui n'ont rien à
voir avec avec l'histoire c'est une
transformation progressive je ne sais
pas ce que les élections législatives
donneront
je crois qu'à la voilà il ya une volonté
d'aller progressivement vers un
changement et vers une démocratisation
tous les jeunes iraniens qui manifestent
n'aspire pas à ce qu'il y ait la guerre
non plus n'aspire pas à ce que leur pays
soit considérée comme l'étape arias ou
la menace numéro un au monde comme l'a
fait construit puis attisé notamment
donald trump
on est dans une situation de tension qui
va et qui vient on verra ce que des
élections législatives donnent mais en
tout cas je pense qu'il faut qu'il y ait
effectivement un changement intéressant
progressif mais pas brusque
les tensions sont toujours vives
aujourd'hui entre téhéran et washington
bien qu'on appelle on entend
régulièrement ses appels au calme là
encore à san juan et le président
iranien prône le dialogue avec les états
unis il dit faire son maximum en gros
pour éviter la guerre quel est votre
regard sur ce qui s'est passé on est
dans un scénario catastrophe si on est
dans un film hollywoodien pour lequel
les scénaristes auraient construit une
montée progressive de la tension
l'intérêt de donald trump était
peut-être de faire croire aux américains
qu'il y avait un danger absolu concentré
uniquement sur l'iran parce qu'on en
oublie la corée du sud on en oublie les
tensions dans le golfe et notamment avec
la situation de de l'arabie saoudite et
des autres pétromonarchies on se
retrouve dans une situation où on a eu
l'impression qu'on était sur le point
d'être dans une forme de troisième
guerre mondiale
mais je crois que les diplomaties et
c'est d'être encore intelligente et de
préserver le monde de cela je crois
qu'il ya une volonté finale enfin de
donald trump de mettre les évangélistes
de son côté qui ont massivement voté
pour lui qu'ils ont peur de cette
apocalypse qui ont peur de ce
basculement dans la violence totale et
c'était aussi probablement une menace
une moyens électorale tout en étant sûr
de lui que les choses ne dérapent pas et
jusqu'à maintenant c'est relativement
préservée mais pour combien de temps
merci beaucoup pour votre analyse
sébastien boussois j'appelle que vous
êtes chercheur en sciences politiques et
relations euro